what is up everybody it's animak here
for
anime uproar and today i will be talking
about some truly major news
about the seven deadly sins series
we just got a brand new seven deadly
sins side story which focuses on
bonn and elaine's son lancelot and this
side story
is clearly intended to serve as an
important setup for the four knights of
the apocalypse sequel series
on top of that the most recent anime
season of the seven deadly sins called
wrath of the gods is now finally
available
on netflix and the next season titled
seven deadly sins
dragon's judgment is scheduled for
january
of 2021 provided that we don't run into
any more delays due to the current
global health crisis as you can tell
there is so much to talk about
so let's get into it if you enjoy the
seven deadly sins content
on this channel and you want us to keep
it going and also cover the sequel
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help
and if you happen to be new to anime
uproar or you just haven't subscribed
yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications if you don't do that
you're going to miss a ton of our videos
even if you're subscribed it's just how
youtube works
feel free to hit me up on twitter and
instagram at animeopror
i'm actually going to be using twitter
and instagram to interact with you guys
about future seven deadly sins video
ideas
if that's something that interests you
definitely follow at anime opera
finally this video will contain seven
deadly sins
manga spoilers and specifically spoilers
for the new
side story with that in mind please
proceed with caution
you have been warned now let's jump
right into the lancelot side story which
is still technically part of the
original seven deadly sins manga not the
sequel
this side story takes place sometime
after the events of chapter 346
and it begins inside the fairy kings
forest where a human king
and a fairy queen rule the couple also
have a son
the young prince lancelot and when we
first see lancelot he looks a lot like a
girl
in fact a human who enters the forest to
sell human artifacts to the fairies
mistakes lancelot for a girl this human
merchant
is actually a grifter he is selling
extremely common human items such as a
mug
a pot and a ladle but he is telling the
fairies that these are rare
ancient human artifacts since the
fairies don't know much about the human
world
they are easily tricked by the human the
fairies are willing to trade much rarer
and more valuable fairy items for these
completely worthless human trinkets
it's all going pretty well for the
merchant until he sees
lancelot at first the merchant can't
even tell whether lancelot is a human or
a fairy
but he is convinced that lancelot is a
girl and an adorable girl
at that he promises to give lancelot an
exceptionally rare human item
if he agrees to meet him after everyone
else has left
the innocent looking lancelot smiles and
agrees
if your creep radar is going off the
charts right now you are exactly right
because the merchant's plan
is to capture lancelot and sell him to
some rich weirdo perverts for a high
price
clearly this human is an absolute piece
of garbage and he reminds me of the
people who tried to do a similar thing
to a young bond
all those years ago but as the merchant
attempts to capture lancelot
he instantly regrets his decision
lancelot punches him in the gut
and threatens to kill him if he ever
comes back lancelot then kicks the
merchant in the face
and sends him flying it is only after
kicking his ass that lancelot tells the
merchant that he is not
a girl lancelot then proceeds to return
all of the items that the fairies traded
to the human
back to their original owners and this
whole little event
tells us quite a few interesting things
about lancelot as a character
clearly he is sharper than the average
fairy because unlike the other fairies
he was not
tricked by the humans lies lancelot is
also strong for his age
because he effortlessly beats up an
adult human even though he is only like
10 years old
finally we see that lancelot has a
strong sense of justice
as the son of the king and queen he
didn't have to involve himself
with this merchant and his scheme
lancelot could have just ignored it or
he could have asked his father or
someone else to handle it
however lancelot felt that it was his
duty to put a stop to the merchant's
scheme
and to return all the items to their
original owners
this tells us that despite being the son
of the king and queen
lancelot is not an elitist he isn't too
stuck up to concern himself with the
affairs of normal people
and he feels that it is his duty to
correct the wrongs committed by the
human merchant
especially since the trickery took place
on the territory that is controlled by
his father
and instead of letting bonn elaine or
jericho patrol the forest and deal with
the law breakers
the young lancelot has taken it upon
himself to carry out those duties
despite his young age in fact lancelot
appears to be a very serious
and responsible young man he considers
just playing around or going on
adventures to be a useless endeavor
meanwhile he considers patrolling the
forest and punishing evil-doers to be a
far more important and useful activity
lancelot even confronts his father bond
and tells him that he should be more
proactive
as king he should be preventing humans
like that merchant from tricking the
fairies and perpetuating their schemes
on their territory lancelot grills bond
about needing to be more aware and
responsible as king
but bond is just like oh sorry
then lancelot says okay it's fine as
long as you understand
and bond responds by saying as expected
of my son
and he proceeds to thank lancelot for
all the help that he has been
to the king as lancelot leaves bonn asks
elaine if she thinks the landslide has
become
more difficult lately and elaine just
says that he's at that age so it makes
sense
man i really loved seeing my boy bond
again
it's been months since the 7th deadly
sins manga ended
and i was so happy to see my favorite
character bon playing an
important part in this side story i also
loved seeing bond interacting with his
family
including elaine and lancelot i always
wondered what kind of parents they would
be and what kind of children they would
have
so this side story has been an awesome
experience for me
personally and speaking of awesome
experiences
we then get to see my girl jericho
jericho is apparently lancelot's master
and she is the one training him i
absolutely love
jericho's new look she now wears her
hair long and loose
and she's got like a black leather
outfit that looks
damn good i've always said that jericho
is a top tier waifu
despite the fact that some seminally
since fans seem to dislike her
i guess they don't like her because she
started out as a villain and a pretty
crappy villain to be honest
and some people don't like her because
they want bonn and elaine to end up
together and so they saw jericho as an
obstacle but i actually love the fact
that jericho started off as a crappy
villain
and developed over the course of the
story into a great character and a
quality waifu when she first appears in
the story
jericho is extremely insecure and she is
willing to do anything to get stronger
including drinking demon blood but
eventually jericho changes
she stops being a villain she falls in
love with pawn and she becomes a force
for good
in britannia i love how her relationship
with bond develops slowly and gradually
and i especially love how despite the
fact that she is in love with bonn
jericho loves bond so much that she
wants him to be happy
even if that means that he won't be with
her after elaine comes back from the
dead
and she nearly kills jericho jericho
still decides to risk her own life
in order to save both bonn and elaine
from galande and melascula
jericho actually risks her life to save
her biggest romantic
rival because she knows that bond would
be devastated if elaine died
and jericho loves bond so much that she
can't bring herself to make him suffer
even if that means sacrificing her own
happiness
compare jericho to someone like vivian
and you'll know why i really like
jericho as a character
and as a waifu and i especially like her
new post
time skip look but back to the story
it turns out that back when he was
visiting leones for tristan's birthday
lancelot got into a fight with tristan
and during that fight lancelot got hit
on the head and he now has a scar
on the right side of his forehead we
also learned that sometime after that
fight
lancelot inherited the ability to read
the hearts of other people from his
mother elaine
this means that he knows what people are
thinking or feeling on the inside even
if they never actually told him their
thoughts and feelings
the chapter then jumps back to that
human merchant
who is trying to escape the forest after
getting that beating from lancelot
but as the merchant attempts to run away
he suddenly vanishes into thin air
it is clear that he has literally
disappeared as a result of some
unknown magic force although at first we
have no idea what kind of force
this is meanwhile back inside the forest
jericho has convinced the young lancelot
to cut his hair
and change his clothes so that he stops
being mistaken for a girl
elaine likes lancelot's new look and
once bond returns from one of his
patrols he decides to unwind with some
delicious
aberdeen ale lancelot wants to try some
aberdeen ale
so bond like every good anime father is
like hey sure my 10 year old son
have some alcohol but only a sip for a
moment lancelot is able to hear the
voice of zhivago
in bond's heart and we see a few
heartwarming sketches
of bonn and zhivago bond's backstory
is definitely my favorite in the entire
series and the seven deadly sins have
some amazing backstories so that's
saying a lot
i love zhivago and his relationship with
bond so i'm not gonna lie i kind of got
goosebumps when i read
this part of the side story very cool
nakaba
very cool lancelot then gets the silly
idea that he can grow up quicker if he
drinks more of the ale
and he ends up downing the entire mug
bonn is like i said one sip you stupid
kid
and both bonn and elaine are concerned
about lancelot since he just drank
so much ale but lancelot says he's fine
the drink was just bitter
and he totally feels like an adult now i
mean i guess lancelot really is a lot
like his father bond
especially when it comes to his
personality he is stubborn
impulsive brave and he likes to drink
booze
right after that bond is informed by
some of the other fairies that they
might have a
problem the merchant who had been in the
forest earlier
vanished into thin air the place where
the merchant disappeared
doesn't have any secret underground
caves or anything like that
and what's more there's been a rumor
going around britannia that humans have
been randomly disappearing
according to the rumors the victims are
always human
and in cases where members of other
races were present those individuals
were always left behind
and only the humans disappear this rumor
has been so persistent that even
meliodas is concerned about it
and so bond decides that they will have
to investigate the situation
first thing in the morning lancelot
immediately asks bond to let him help
out with the mission and he promises to
be useful
but bond refuses and tells lancelot to
go back to the castle
bond looks pretty stern and serious in
this moment
and it is clear that he is concerned
about this disappearing phenomenon
and he definitely doesn't want his son
getting mixed up in any of this
once they returned to the castle that
night bond expressed his concern to
elaine about lancelot changing recently
ever since he went to leones lancelot
has been trying to act more like an
adult
and he's been a lot more serious and
responsible bond thinks that the reason
why lancelot might be changing is
because he unlocked the ability to read
hearts back when he was in leonis
and so bonn is worried that this new
power might have changed
lancelot but elaine assures bond that
she has that very same power so lancelot
was bound to unlock it
the ability to read hearts alone is not
enough to change someone's personality
and in fact elaine tells bond that he is
the real reason why lance a lot has
changed
bonn is confused at first but elaine
explains that when lancelot went to
leonis
he realized what a respected person his
father was
what a heroic warrior his father was and
how legendary the exploits of the seven
deadly sins were
on top of that just like he did with
tristan gother used his powers to show
lancelot
the full story of his father bond and
his father's history with the seven
deadly sins
this is what inspired lancelot to change
he wants to become a great knight like
bond and he wants to be recognized and
respected by his father
that is why lancelot is suddenly so
interested in being serious and acting
like a grown-up he doesn't want to be
just a little kid anymore who goes
around playing games
he wants to become a powerful ruler and
knight like his father bonn
and he wants to live up to the legend of
his father
thanks to elaine bond finally
understands what's going on with
lancelot
and as lancelot sleeps in his bed that
night bond tucks him in and tells him
that he doesn't need to rush to become
an adult
i thought that this was a really great
and heartwarming moment
especially knowing what a difficult
childhood bond had had
and how he had no choice but to grow up
way too fast
the fact that bon now wants to protect
his son and wants him to just enjoy his
childhood is beautiful
and makes perfect sense within the
context of bond's story
when he wakes up the next day lancelot
ventures out on his own and he is
carrying his makeshift spear
or i guess we can call it a lance to
stay on brand
on his walk lancelot encounters jericho
and in that very moment
bond snaps awake in the dream that he
just had
bond saw himself back in his childhood
in the very moment that he decided to
rush
in to rob a mansion without waiting for
trivago and this was despite the fact
that bond was specifically instructed to
wait
for his father this moment led to bond
being captured and beaten by the owners
of the mansion
and he lost contact with zhivago after
that
at least for the time being after
recalling such a traumatic moment in his
dream
bond goes out to look for lance a lot
but he realizes that lancelot is gone
lancelot has disobeyed his father's
orders and he has decided to investigate
the disappearing humans phenomenon on
his own
thankfully jericho had a feeling that
lancelot would go out alone
so she decides to accompany him lancelot
wants bond to take him seriously and to
stop
treating him like a kid and lancelot
believes that solving this mystery is
the perfect opportunity to earn
bonds respect as it begins to rain
lancelot and jericho suddenly see a spot
where the rain
appears to split it is as if everything
is being rained on
except for a single spot which is about
the size of a large doorway
at first lancelot and jericho think that
this might be an illusion
but lancelot remembers that it had also
rained back when the human merchant had
disappeared
suddenly lancelot and jericho hear a
voice
the voice says quick come here
jericho wants to retreat and tell bonn
about it but the stubborn and reckless
lancelot decides that he will rush
in alone jericho can't let this happen
so instead of going back to get bond she
grabs lancelot's hand
and the two of them walk inside the
mysterious doorway together
as they do they both appear to vanish
into
thin air okay so i guess jericho isn't
the best babysitter but she's still
really hot okay
we then see bond rushing through the
forest in an attempt to find lancelot
but as we know it's too late by the time
bond arrives to the spot where the
doorway had been
lancelot and jericho are gone and so is
the rain
that means that the doorway itself is
gone and bond will not
be able to follow lancelot the text on
the final page
tells us that bonn and elaine searched
for lancelot and jericho for
years but their search didn't yield
any results finally several years later
prince lancelot returned as the prince
of the lake
but that is for another story the
sidebar of the page
also tells us to stay tuned because the
sequel manga
is being worked on as we speak this
is a pretty frustrating ending for all
of us who want more answers about what
just happened
but this side story definitely serves as
a great setup for the sequel
you better believe that i am now
extremely curious to find out what is
going to happen to lancelot and jericho
and what bond and elaine are going to do
now that their son is lost
at least for the time being thankfully
arthurian legend provides us with some
important
answers about what just happened to
lancelot
we all know that the 7 deadly sins
series is very heavily influenced by the
legend of king arthur
and the knights of the round table in
the past i made an entire video talking
about all the clues that arthurian
legend can provide us with for the
upcoming sequel
but this new side story gives us some
completely new
insight on the direction that the sequel
manga might take
in arthurian legend lancelot and tristan
are close friends
and they are among the strongest knights
of the round table
in the legend lancelot is the son of
king bon and queen elaine just like in
the seven deadly sins
but in arthurian lore king bond and
queen elaine are forced to flee their
kingdom by an
enemy king and they take the young
lancelot with them
as bond dies in elaine's arms
the young lancelot is taken by the lady
of the lake
and she then raises him inside her
magical realm
as a result of this unique upbringing
lancelot is sometimes called
lancelot duluck or lancelot
of the lake as we know the lady of the
lake has already been introduced
in the seven deadly sins story although
we know very little about her
we just know that she is a powerful
magical being created by chaos
and that she has access to secret
magical knowledge
clearly the seven deadly sins manga and
the sequel are not going to follow
arthurian legend exactly
ban and elaine were not forced to flee
by an enemy king and
bond did not die however it is clear
from this lancelot side story that
lancelot has just been taken
by the lady of the lake just like in the
original arthurian tale
why else would he eventually return as
the prince of the lake
which is very similar to the original
legend in which he returns as
lancelot of the lake continuing on with
lancelot in arthurian legend
we know that he is going to be knighted
and become one of the knights of the
round table
the lady of the lake will also give him
a powerful magical ring
that can break through any spell and i
expect that this ring might play an
important role
in the sequel beyond that we know that
lancelot is supposed to become involved
in a forbidden love affair
believe it or not lancelot has an affair
with queen guinevere
the wife of king arthur himself now
obviously we know that the seven deadly
sins take huge liberties with the
arthurian legend story
so i don't actually expect lancelot to
steal arthur's girl
although that would be a pretty crazy
twist but such raunchy romantic
intrigue just doesn't seem to fit into
the seven deadly sins world
at least that's my personal opinion i am
very curious to see why the lady of the
lake
in the world of the seven deadly sins
decided to take lancelot and raise him
inside her magical realm
in the original legend she raises
lancelot because his father king bond
dies but clearly that is not the case
here
also we know that in the world of the
summer deadly sins the lady of the lake
has a close connection to chaos power
and to excalibur so i wonder if chaos
power is going to play a role
in lancelot's upbringing slash training
at any rate
this entire side story was a very
interesting development
first we got to see how bond and elaine
are doing and we finally met
their son lancelot but then the side
story took a much darker turn
as bonn and elaine lost their son at
least for a number of years
and the culprit appears to be the lady
of the lake
we still don't know what exactly the
lady of the lake wants with lancelot
and i honestly can't wait to find out
more after this
massive cliffhanger i must say that i am
very excited for the sequel manga
but let me know what you guys think did
you enjoy this lancelot side story
and does it make you more excited for
the sequel
also do you like lancelot as a character
and why do you think that he was
seemingly abducted by the lady of the
lake
please share your thoughts down in the
comments below
and most importantly let me know if you
agree with me that jericho
is a top tier waifu even if she isn't
the greatest babysitter
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more seven deadly sins
and sequel content right here on the
channel please leave a like to let me
know
and if you happen to be new to anime
uproar or you just haven't subscribed
yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications remember that you
really have to go through the trouble of
hitting that bell and selecting the
option that says
all that is the only way to make sure
that youtube will actually show you
our videos you can also follow me on
twitter and instagram
at anime uproar i want to give a big
thank you to all of our
anime emperor patrons who make videos
like this one possible
an extra special thank you to alpha a
disciple
of lord twego himself and i can't forget
are the one tier patrons the ones who
rise above
all other clans including ingrata
alolan adam the world steelers acquired
respect
pate heffer jonathan king brandon aviles
papa smurf emperor otaku thomas jones
and kin mano finally big thank you to
all of our pro hero tier
patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh nothing but a fan
jason wilson king zeldris anatoly
kazatsky angel cruz cricket xp
joe stanton very gucci alicia octor
jessica kayla
hinokami and water bonnie parks
wrathween de ora deadly saint and stern
hawkins
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value to you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patreon exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos
along with these amazing people as
always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you